nick witgren will serve as the opener as
the indians go for a bullpen game here
tonight and you can see the numbers for
nick this year two and seven 54
appearances coming out of that bullpen
58 strikeouts in his 56 in the third
this will be his first career start how
about that
bouncing ball to bobby bradley he'll
take it himself one away
and here's nikki lopez
here's another base hit nicki's third
today
straw cuts it off deep nikki's digging
for second and the throw is in time but
late
nikki lopez has a one-out hustling
double yes 18th on the season i love
that pop-up slide
so after a ground out by merrifield the
royals have a double and now
back-to-back walks and carlos santana
will come up with the bases loaded and
one out
nope up and away for a third straight
walk
mickey lopez
comes down from third and the boos
come down on whit grin as the royals
take a one-nothing lead
hunter drove in three with a two-run
home run and an rbi single in game one
and he hits that in the air to right
field
deep
reyes is going to make the play on the
track
salvi comes down from third dozier is
driven in four today and the royals lead
two nothing in the first inning stay hot
hunter way to go and
not try to pull it and the 1-2
is popped to center
mile straw
makes the catch
and it's two-nothing kansas city as the
indians come to batman uel piops will
make his first big league start it's his
34th appearance of the year let's hope
it's better than woodgrin's not real big
guy
alberto was the only man to beat on the
left side and he hit it right at him and
pions gets the indians quickly one two
three in the first
bottom of the second inning and front
meal race will lead off for cleveland
rips it fair over the bag at third down
into the left field corner and the big
guy rolls into second base with the
lead-off double it's his 17th on the
year and the indians get a man in
scoring position
and now you chang steps to the plate
oh and pion strikes him out of the
breaking ball down and away i love it
he's acting like a real starting pitcher
he's taking advantage of this
opportunity
runner going and an out thank you very
much fran mia reyes tried to steal third
with two outs it's his first career
thrown out runner right there
congratulations
two and on nikki lopez he doubled with
one out in the first inning and scored
the royals first run
and he hits it hard
again another multi-hit game
nikki lopez has 11 multi-hit games in
his last 17.
[Applause]
nice swing again salvador perez is
really the one that got that ending
going when he walked in the first
there's a ball wrapped up the alley left
center by salvador perez flying around
third nikki lopez going to try to score
here's the throw of the plate it's a
good one and they
got him
nicely done miles straw to andres
jimenez and on a couple of hops to
roberto perez to get the speedy lopez
and keeps it a two to nothing game i
think pushing the envelope right there
but they wanted to try it two good
throws you got a chance to get him and
you know you want to try and get perez
that rbi and send him even though nobody
was out straw gets it bear hands it and
there's your cutoff man two good throws
and able to get lopez and he was flying
he hustled all the way around and
couldn't get in it's a good relay
about pions 23 pitches we're in the
third inning you know and how many did
we see in our last home stand how many
starters two over 20 in the first pitch
i mean in the first inning a lot
[Music]
strike three
and it looked like it was well in the
strike zone perez isn't happy with home
plate umpire jeremy riggs look at that
right on the outside corner and prez
come on man you're a catcher you know
that's a good pitch so you got to go
here's andre simenas oh for three in the
opener
jimenez launches one deep if it's fair
it's way gone and it is a home run the
indians get on the board
home run number four for andres jimenez
there was no doubt it had the length
it's just a matter what it curled inside
or outside the pole it stayed fair
and the indians are on the board cutting
the lead to two to one well he's got all
of it he knew it's just a matter of
staying fair so not quite but the royals
will take the two and a third from pions
new pitcher on for the tribe and it is
the major league pitching debut for
anthony ghost ghost was an outfielder
for several different organizations but
saw some real nice big league time with
the tigers but has not appeared in a
major league game since may the 15th of
2016 was sent down to the minor leagues
and did not get back as a position
player but now he is back as a pitcher
for the cleveland indians
well six of seven were 100 miles an hour
but it's a lead-off walk and here's
hanzer alberto
hit hard and fair up the left field line
isabelle to third and he will be held as
hanzo alberto has a double and now the
infield comes in with runners at second
and third
breaking ball is grounded to the right
side
and rivero avoids the strikeout and gets
isbell down from third and the royals
lead 3-1
so it's two and two on the royals
catcher with one out
basis empty
top half of the fifth inning
up the ladder he goes and strikes him
out well he knew it he was going to
chase it and you can see perez shake his
head
man i told myself not to swing at it 39
pitches for anthony ghost 27 of them
strikes boy you can see the stuff is
there camaro hale gave him a pat on the
chest as ghost makes his return to the
big leagues tonight for the first time
since 2016 excuse me and now
we'll have another new picture now
lisbell reached on a fielder's choice in
the fourth inning and scored on
sebastian rivero's ground out
sliced into the left field corner and
beyond zimmer and isbell stops at second
base for the two out double now base hit
could make it 4-1 and the battle will be
hanzer alberto who doubled his last time
up
and there's your ground ball into right
field isbell's gonna be waved home by
vance wilson
and the throw is going to arrive late
so a two outs and nobody on isbell
doubles
answer alberto picks up his second hit
the indians down to their final out with
bobby bradley coming up
the one-two is
hit a ton
deep center field that's how you make
amends
and the big globe hauls it in
bobby bradley's 14th of the year and
folks i'm telling you
you won't see a guy go from pillar to
post
on two pitches like we just saw with
bobby bradley that's almost like harold
ramirez right there
don't let it happen come on scotty boy
get him
and he does
and the royals sweep the doubleheader in
cleveland
outstanding work man was that some solid
pitching mike matheny he's got to be
excited about this win just like he did
that first one barlow nice job don't
even let them have a guy in there and
walk about house good good work guys all
fired up so a very good start to the
last road trip of the year and now we
update the numbers the royals have won
14 of their last 20
on the road
you